reflect briefly on the varying
friendships relationships and social
groups that you are a part of consider
how different they are person to person
group to group and how your own
personality often changes depending on
whom you are with this is because humans
are socially echoic we conform our
behavior to echo the behavior of those
around us each social encounter we
engage in carries with it its own unique
character a weighted average of all the
personalities involved we are merely
actors constantly playing different
roles to suit the different scenes we
enter in life our ability to adapt to
and reflect these shared scenes and
personalities is what allows us to
experience successful friendships and
relationships what we must be careful of
though is what seems in life we choose
to enter we must be selective of whom we
surround ourselves with we must be aware
of how compatible and mutually valuable
our friends and partners are to us if
not we risk losing sight of our core
self and what we stand for we risk
reducing our intellect and individuality
the saying that a team is only as strong
as their weakest link is very much
applicable to the science of human
sociality therefore it is important that
we strive to have a balance of
relationships that challenge and support
us like childhood bullies suffering from
insecurity people love to bring others
down to their level so they don't feel
quite so alone don't let these people
infect you
you have the privileged ability to
choose who you spend time with in life
choose wisely
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder